hay nueve libros de misterios seis de no
ficción diez de ficción y cinco cuentos
de hadas haz una gráfica de barras para
esta información aquí vamos a crear la
gráfica de barras tenemos aquí el número
de libros y el género del libro entonces
tenemos nueve libros de misterio
así que elevó esta barra hasta el número
nueve tenemos seis libros de no ficción
entonces elevó esta barra hasta el
número seis
tenemos 10 libros de ficción
entonces elevó esta barra hasta arriba
aquí está el número 10
y tenemos
5 cuentos de hadas
entonces bueno esta sería la gráfica de
barras para esta información comprobamos
la respuesta perfecto hagamos otro más
isabella lanzó cuatro pelotas lanzó las
pelotas a 9 12 12 y 10 metros hace un
gráfico de línea para las distancias
entonces qué información se nos da dice
que lanzó las pelotas a 9 entonces una
la lanzó a 9
una pelota 12
otra pelota 12
y una 10 metros y esa es nuestra gráfica
de línea compruebo la respuesta perfecto
hagamos otro dice hay 5 libros en una
repisa las alturas de los libros son 32
36 38 32 y 35 centímetros haz un gráfico
de línea con las alturas aquí tenemos
una recta numérica y por cada cantidad
que tengamos aquí vamos a poner un punto
en esa cantidad entonces dice que las
alturas de los libros son 32 36 38 32 y
35 centímetros entonces 32 tenemos un
libro de 32 centímetros
vamos a colocar aquí un punto en 32
tenemos uno de 36 centímetros colocamos
aquí un punto
tenemos uno de 38 colocamos aquí un
punto otro de 32 centímetros entonces
aquí van dos puntos y uno de 35 entonces
aquí va un punto y eso es la gráfica de
línea con esas alturas para estos libros
hagamos otro ejercicio
aquí dice nicklas encontró cuatro orugas
sus longitudes fueron de 61 64 64 y 64
milímetros aquí están las orugas y dice
haz un gráfico de línea con las
longitudes entonces que tenemos una
recta numérica y por cada una de las
longitudes de las orugas vamos a poner
aquí en la recta numérica un punto y ese
será nuestra gráfica de línea entonces
en 61 ponemos un punto
en 64 ponemos un punto otra vez
ponemos otro punto en 64 y otra vez
entonces hubo una oruga de longitud 61
milímetros y hubo 3 de 64 milímetros
comprobamos la respuesta y terminamos